اللي بيشتغلوا على الحرف
البصريا يعني مثلك هم عندهم ميل عندهم
ميله النص الوجداني التصوفي العرفاني اكثر
وللنصوص
خلينا نقول ايضا للشعر
الكلاسيكي العربي لانه ايضا انت بتتحدث عن
علاقه الحرف في الايقاع
والزمن
الشعر الموزون عند العرب يعني في في هذه
الوحدات اللي هي فيها صوتيات وبصريات من
نفس الوقت يعني انت وقت اللي تتفلت من كل
منظومه الايقاع الكلاسيكي بالشعر وتذهب
الى القصيده النسر لتبني عليها
مناخات بصريه يمكن بكون يمكن اريح لك شوي
كمان بكون الوضع عن
ياتي السؤال
مدهش بصراحه لاول مره يطرح علي سؤال
[موسيقى]
من هذه الزاويه صحيح بمرحله معينه اشتغلت
كثيرا على على النصوص
على ايقاع اللغه ايا كانت
يعني مثلا الشعر الفرنسي شغلت عليه كثيرا
كان عندي معرض من شهرين بفرنسة تجيد اللغه
الفرنسيه يعني اجيدها استيعاضا وليس كلام
الانجليزي ممكن او
فانشغلت عن نص الفرنسي وهذا البحث اهم
البحث تحويل الايقاع والصوره الى الى لغه
مغايره يعني من منجز لغوي الى منجز بصري